goods and services and the EU has been
finding internal solutions and there
some I dragged us on to their territory
the the most persuasive thing about the
paper is that bit where Shankar outlines
the fact that in order to arrive at a
deal you have to play four dimensional
chess and we've been barely playing two
dimensional chess and we need to come
back to that kind of intricate solution
the only thing where I would say I
probably would have said a little bit
more is about that this is not about
reducing standards is not about reducing
rights it is about a global standards
which do not undermine any of our social
fabric and the things which we think are
important to us but there is one thing
which is is true there is no time to try
and put the Humpty Dumpty of checkers
back together again but there is time to
get a free-trade agreement there is time
to make sure that we leave in March next
year on orderly terms which are in
everyone's interest and I think that's
what we should focus on we can come back
to the Lancaster vision which I think
was the right way forward I just want to
leave on a personal note I have spent 50
months of my life
negotiating with someone called Michel
Barnier and what that experience taught
me is that it will always be the last 48
hours which are the most significant but
also the most brutal I was surprised
that Salzburg was quite as brutal as it
was it was not that I didn't think it
would get that way I was slightly
earlier I'm glad they're two women on
the panel here this morning because I do
wonder whether the 24 men would have
behaved quite the way to British prime
minister and the humiliation about
tweeting out pictures of cakes so what I
would just say to my fellow Europeans
brexit is important it's important for
us and for you to get this right stop
playing childish silly boy games we are
leaving in March 29th this is
a really important step to take us there
and we have the time to get to that
withdrawal agreement on the basis
largely outlined here
[Applause]
géza thank you very much David well it's
a pleasure to be here in support of IAEA
report number 95 it's a certain Soviet
connotation to that and can I start by
commending what Jesus just said and I
think that demonstrates quite how a
matter of national interest like this
completely transcends party political
interest so now I Shankar highlighted in
the report and in detail when you read
it you'll see it the global trading
systems going in entirely the wrong
direction every all the experts agree
this from the director-general of the
World Trade Organization on down and
what that means is that Britain has a
particularly huge role once it has left
the European Union available to it we
don't get it automatically but available
it is a huge role and this amplifies the
effect of any free trade policy we have
it amplifies the effect in global terms
and it amplifies it in British terms and
it means therefore the returns to
trading the rest of the world is much
greater than you would otherwise assess
and of course it's traditional that
people underestimate the gains from free
trade even New Zealand that that
champion of free trade underestimated
some of its free trade arrangements The
effect of it by 500 percent 500 percent
and I expect us to see equally large
impacts when we actually get into the
free trade deals that we ought to what
this means is as Jesus said is we need
to reset the negotiations we're
currently bluntly in a cul-de-sac I'm
afraid I slightly disagree Giza
I think Salzburg was unfortunately all
too predictable she may be right about
timing but I'm afraid it was all too
predictable how it would turn out either
here or in October now what we need to
do is to use the original commitments
made back on March the 7th I think by
both tusk
and Barney a to go for an advanced
free-trade agreement and the reason that
this is called plan a plus is what we
need is an FTA plus a free trade
agreement plus and to do that we need an
and again the report goes into this in
some detail to do that we need to use
our allies as Shankar said the rest of
the world does not see European
negotiation as a gold standard just the
opposite they see it as an outlier they
see it as anti-competitive they see it
as protectionist incidentally one of the
reasons that many big companies like
European negotiation is precisely
because it is protectionist there's a
tremendous case study in here of the
reach the chemical that goes the
chemical standards and how that works
and really how even the Commission
recognize that it's ineffective and bad
now I don't agree with every word of
what Shang has written will be very
surprising in a 130 odd pages that to
different people degree the same but I
agree with ninety or percent of it it's
probably true to say that this have been
the white paper I'd still be in
government today so we need to take a
model like this we need to grasp the
brexit price and we need to act properly
for the enormous benefits to be had from
a proper free trade policy thank you
[Applause]
David many thanks Jacob can ask you to
take to the stage well ladies and
gentlemen it is gloriously appropriate
that we are talking about free trade in
the Gladstone library because Gladstone
got rid of more tariffs in his budgets
than any other Chancellor of the
Exchequer in history and he took over
four and a half hours to do so which
will be glad to know I'm not going to do
the great virtue of this plan is that it
is deliverable it is based on precedence
and extending what is already done and
it works towards a brexit prize keep
that mind phrase in your minds because
so much of what we have about these
negotiations has been about managing
decline has been about how do you have
the least bad brexit this is about how
you have a fantastic brexit that sets us
up for the next generation and ensures
our prosperity so it's a really exciting
and good paper looking at Britain's
position not just in the European
context but globally and the key to it
to my mind is that it is deliverable
bear in mind as David says this has been
offered to us by the Commission they
have offered us the best trade deal they
have done with any country ever in the
world so if you want to call it
Canada Plus or super Canada or
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
Canada that is what is being aimed at
and it's being offered as long as you
can solve the Northern Ireland question
which I think the ERG did a week or so
ago so you've got Northern Ireland
solved you've got a free trade deal
you've got something that is deliverable
and then the question is will it work
within the country at large well we know
that trekkers went and we know that
there is nervousness about leaving
purely on world trade terms so if people
are focusing on what the real options
are after the EU has comprehensively
snubbed the prime minister and the
country then the real option that faces
the nation is do we have a free trade
deal or do we leave on world trade terms
and I think that reality that
consciousness will ensure that if
there's got to the House of Commons it
would be passed so it's not just
deliverable in terms of the European
Union its deliverable in terms of
British public opinion and it's
deliverable in terms of parliamentary
betes
I think this paper is therefore the most
exciting contribution we have had for
this debate in many months thank you
[Applause]
Jacob thank you very much and last but
by no means least Teresa thank you well
I'm I'm delighted to be here to commend
this very impressive piece of work
whilst there are one or two minor points
where I diverge from the paper the
overall plan is a sensible practical way
forward to delivering the right brexit
outcome it is a deliverable blueprint to
deliver a wide-ranging free trade
agreement between the European Union and
the United Kingdom it's in line with the
Lancaster House speech and as others
have emphasized it's also very much in
line with the way countries around the
world do business day-in day-out we're
not asking for anything exceptional from
the European Union and as we all know
the Irish border has been the blockage
which has caused progress towards a
comprehensive free trade agreement to
stall this is the key reason behind the
proposals in the checkers poem so if we
can find a way to maintain the drive
through border we have on the island of
Ireland but within the context of a
trade deal we can unlock the
negotiations and put them back on track
to a Canada plus type arrangement the
Arg paper last week proposed how we do
just that the approach set out in
frankerz document today has a number of
similarities with the ERG plan though it
takes a different approach in certain
respects for example on continued
harmonization of rules
on animals and food between Northern
Ireland in the European Union but these
ie these proposals should be seen as a
further indication that the border
question does not require the
compromises of the checkers plan that
there are ways to make the border work
pretty much as it does today without the
common rule book or the complex customs
arrangements in the checkers light paper
and this can be done within existing
technology and within existing legal and
administrative procedures so we can
legitimately seek a free trade agreement
with the EU whilst maintaining a
free-flowing border without harming the
integrity of the single market that's
what the ERG paper set out to do and
today this document is making the same
point albeit with a subtly different
plan to answer that question and I think
also today's report makes the vital
point that actually around the world
there's a trend towards reducing the
cost of customs compliance making it
more streamlined making it more based on
systems rather than individual
transactions so it would be a great pity
if the entire future of the United
Kingdom's economic relationship with its
European neighbors was to falter on the
basis of customs paperwork which is
becoming increasing increasingly easy to
do across borders around the world so I
think a very good message to take away
from today's event and from the report
that it's here to launch is that it's
time to put a draft free-trade agreement
on the table in Brussels and start some
serious negotiations
[Applause]
Teresa thank you very much we do have
some time for questions we have a
microphone coming down the aisle so do
put your hand in the oath you'd like to
ask question I would be keen to take
questions about policy rather than
politics if that's possible
I'll start with Feisal Sky News and the
report acknowledges that under this plan
there will be some frictions that you
have to mitigate so whatever the prize
in the future can I just ask the panel
those industries and those workers in
those industries that might face
immediate frictions are their jobs or
their pay do they deserve to be told
about them now in advance of the deal
being done and can I ask the politicians
on the panel whether they think there's
anything in what the Prime Minister has
said that will lead her to abandon
checkers for this plan well thank you
I'll start with Shanker and actually
then just work on the panel thank you
for that question Shankar thanks for
that question
um so I I don't think it's binary and
one of the things we say in the plan
you know losses that we're doing two
things here we're trying to maximize the
opportunities and we're trying to
minimize the disruptions it's not a
binary choice we think there are
sufficient mitigant in here to take if
there are any frictions and friction is
on a spectrum is either zero or there is
you know highly untrusted order what
we're trying to do is to take what
currently exists which is not zero it
there are existing things and and and
mitigate for how that changes and we
think we are able to do that it's not
one thing it's a series of different
customs proposals to ensure that supply
chains work and it basically as Theresa
I actually said there is a whole new you
know thinking in the customs world that
is moving from goods trade where where
you do the transactions tied to the
goods moving themselves to trader system
based transactions so it's more like
filing you know a tax return for very
very trusted supply chains and so we
think that it's solvable we think you
can do that but the bigger question is
if you can do that if you can increase
those frictions only a little you know
the minimal amount the real question is
do you then because you can do that keep
the options the opportunities on the
table and that's what I think is the
most important thing and I think that's
what's been most missing from the from
the debate these are I wonder if our
glass our panelists as well response
because you've just highlighted one of
the things which has bedeviled this
whole debates you sort of talk about
mitigating friction and then there's a
good journalist you want to know how
many jobs are said equal and as the
paper explains it's it's it's a kind of
four dimensional chess you're playing
here on making these arrangements and if
you talk to the big companies you know
if you've talked to your BMWs your VW's
who need global supply chains they just
want to know what the rules are and they
will meet them and so there will be
things done differently but I'm afraid I
can't help you with the headline which
says this will be seven and a half jobs
David first you say is there are
frictions now and/or Niland that there's
a visible border but it's not no border
the bae border an excise border the
whole series of forms you have to fill
or an IRA citizen you cross the border
you might also find that there's a
personnel border too if you want about
the continental border if you if you
look back through your own television
archives you'll find thirty five days of
delays at Calais because of a french
strike I think in 2015 so there are
frictions now let's not pretend they're
not secondly so the frictions are not
not lethal they're just things to be
managed and I thought when the
interesting examples of that this
recently was I think it was BMW one of
the car firms anyway announced that they
were going to move their annual
maintenance period to immediately after
after the brexit day and this was hell
of a so look look at the damage but they
always have an annual maintenance period
and it lasts for weeks I think so if
they can handle weeks of delay because
their maintenance why can't they handle
hours
delay because of an irritating French
customs official and in terms of the
what we say to the workforce well the
first thing we said workforces we're not
going to exaggerate the cost of borders
to ridiculous levels which is what's
happened so far in this debate we have
seen numbers about the costs of friction
of the borders which are just
unbelievable and if you want to test
that go talk to the Swiss who will give
you numbers at about 1% of what are
being claimed by those who try to make a
scare story out of this ok thank you I
follow on from that six seconds of
delays in goods coming in via
Southampton well you get longer delays
when there's a minor jam on the m25 for
just-in-time delivery and I think you
really do have to contextualize this but
you have to accept the fact that we are
leaving the European Union and therefore
it will be different and to try and
pretend it'll be the same once we've
left its cloud cuckoo-land that's not
what people voted for on your question
of with the prime will the Prime
Minister accept this well I think the
Prime Minister is a lady of singular
wisdom and therefore is likely to
recognize the reality the checkers
doesn't have much support either in this
country or abroad and that this plan
solves all her problems and with her
wisdom and insight I'm sure she will be
thinking very carefully about adopting
it teresa reached these negotiations
fully informed about the consequences in
terms of our economy but what today is
about is demonstrating that actually
consequences for our economy can be
incredibly positive if we seize this
opportunity to agree a free trade
agreement and it is important to put in
context you know the the source of the
dispute ie the formalities and the
frictions that come with a customs
barrier and I think you know the detail
of this paper puts forward its
incredible and practical and convincing
solutions to ensure that we reduce and
minimize that friction within the
context of as Jacob points out a
different relationship between the UK
and the rest
European Union has been the case in the
past thank you let me come back to the
floor Gary you just wait till the
microphone gets to you Gary
thank you very much kind of given
Channel 4 News - on the document if I
may some people saying you can't
possibly expect India or another major
economy to get involved in serious trade
negotiations until they know what our
relationship is with EU you're saying
flour ahead now what's what's the answer
to that it also looks in the document as
though you're saying when it comes to
food regulation and areas like labor and
environment law we should move a bit
towards America and away from Europe a
lot of people would be very fearful of
that why shouldn't they be and may ask
one to the politicians on the panel
which is you're saying that trees may
had this plan in her back pocket it was
the implication of Lancaster House do
you really believe that or do you think
thanks the house was a bit of a decoy
put there to keep you on the journey
Shanker perhaps I can ask you to do with
the two questions about the document and
then I'll ask about my guest house
speech and it's it's yes um thank you
Gary um with respect to agreements with
other countries and and whether it's the
US or India or any of the countries that
we suggested all CP TVP accession these
are things that we need to be
progressing now every country that's
involved in a trade negotiation knows
that it's negotiating with people who
are also negotiating other things with
other people they do know this and it is
part of the negotiating dynamics what I
think we mustn't do and what I think the
key recommendation that we've made here
is that what we mustn't do is say all of
our trade policy for the whole world is
going to be judged through this EU UK
lens because if we do that then we'll
end up on the EU battlefield and we will
end up with an agreement that will
preclude all the benefits that we could
have in other areas which is not
necessary because we can concurrently
negotiate lots of countries concurrently
negotiate deals with lots of people
Mexico for example had negotiated
literally tens of trade agreements in 30
or 40 it is Cape your cape
doing this and there's a huge advantage
to doing it because actually as we've
said these various the pillars of our
trade policy that I've that I've
suggested the unilateral bilateral or
lateral multilateral pillars they they
can mutually reinforce each other they
can help you get a better deal with the
EU if the EU sees that we are
negotiating seriously with the US and
with CP TPP and others if they see that
they will they may not like it they may
shout and scream about it but they will
react differently to you if they think
that you are the only if they think that
you think for their the only game in
town
then they will make hay with you and I
think that is what is happening and
that's a problem with respect to this
question about regulation we are not
suggesting and we never have suggested
sort of massive deregulation that's not
what we're suggesting here what we're
suggesting is better regulation what
we're suggesting is what is the global
norm the global norm based on the WTO in
the OECD and other organizations is that
you want to regulate in ways that are
the least trade restrictive the least
anti-competitive consistent with a
legitimate regulatory goal that's the
goal of your regulatory process and
that's what everyone broadly in the
world has has agreed where I think the
EU has diverged from that then
absolutely yes I think we want to take a
different approach because actually when
you regulate in ways that are
anti-competitive or trade restrictive
you destroy wealth out of the economy
and I think that's happened in in the EU
28 over the last few years and I think
we do want to see the advantages of
moving away from that but we can do that
and still have a framework of regulatory
recognition with the EU those regulatory
recognition all over the world the EU
and New Zealand having the agreed
regulatory recognition for meat products
trade know so very very sensitive
subject New Zealand and the EU have
recognized underlying product regulation
even though those product regulations
differ so it is capable of happening
they can do it and that's what I would
recommend
please see the checkers it's a European
Union designs on the free trade plus
it's us that decides and will decide
because what we've already said in our
discussions with them to try and get the
same outcomes or similar outcomes
equally high health equally high safety
he equally high quality but in a
pro-competitive way not a protectionist
way so that's the distinction
now as for Lancaster House Jacob quite
rightly said the primus is a wise lady
she's also a lady a very integrity and
Lancaster House was met as we've
mentioned house and I can say that with
absolute certainty cuz I helped write
them thanks so much let me come back I
know there was lots of other questions
let me take Henry here Thank You Henry
maps from the Financial Times
mystery smoke you say the question is
whether the country will wear this plan
better than it's prepared to wear the
checkers proposal is the obvious
solution to that not to offer it to the
country and a referendum alongside Mrs
May Pam I'll take I think mark who
answered the question answered the
question I could but the truth is the
people who are campaigning for a second
referendum want to stop us leaving the
European Union that's what the campaign
is about it's nothing to do with getting
the people to decide deciding the forms
of a trade agreement is the routine
matter of a parliamentary democracy for
Parliament changing your fundamental
constitutional arrangements isn't
appropriate matter for a referendum
we've had that referendum but even more
we had that referendum based on a
manifesto commitment from David Cameron
in 2015 and we had it affirmed by the
2017 general election when both parties
major parties said that they would
implement the result of the referendum
so we've had three national votes on
leaving the European Union and I'm
afraid the remain as who want another
referendum hold democracy in contempt
they lost and they should grow up
[Applause]
it's Chris Morris from BBC Shanker I'd
note your report says that you admit
many of the things in it our minority
opinion do you say but we're the
economic consensus the IMF the OECD the
government's own analysis and that
applies in in many ways I think to your
solutions in Northern Ireland as well
and on the Irish border I'm genuinely
interested in why why do you think all
these other economists and experts have
got it so wrong and you got it so right
and for the politicians on the panel how
much friction how much extra friction in
trade with Europe is acceptable when
Jacob you mentioned six seconds at
Southampton but as you all know much for
the trade between the EU and the UK is
food and animal stuff which comes in
every day
EU rules on that are extremely strict I
think it's 100 percent of document
checks in about 50% of physical checks
that's going to be more than six seconds
so I think one of the things that
obviously a lot of businesses up and
down the country would like to know from
this is how much more delay is
acceptable in your opinion because
they're the ones are going to have to
deal with it on a day to day basis
Shanker can I start with you and then
run down the panel absolutely so just on
economic analysis first of all it is not
just us that believe that there is a
benefit to if the UK is able to adopt an
independent trade and royalty policy and
therefore reduce barriers around the
world but that will give a significant
economic gain the OECD has said this the
OECD has said that for developed
countries reduction of a regulatory
reform reduction of regulatory barriers
can amount to five to seven percent of
GDP which is an order of magnitude
bigger than which not much larger than
the boarder barrier
reduction so border bow reductions might
give you about a two percent increase in
GDP behind the border barriers
distortions are much much bigger and the
point of course is that they're
increasing as Azevedo has said that
these these distortions and global
regulatory protections Amin's massively
on the increase since the financial
crisis so you're you're sort of looking
at
very very large amount of trade barriers
and regulatory distortions that you can
do something about with your independent
policy if if in fact that wasn't the
case if the world was going
fantastically well and the trading
system was doing fantastically well then
clearly that that gain would be much
much less and that's what we say in the
in the in the paper I would say that
there have been all sorts of economic
analyses done about things like the Euro
done about things like the ERM done
about all kinds of different policy
decisions that a country could make that
have been frequently wrong the point
that we're trying to make is it's very
very hard to model this and David gave
the example of New Zealand and the
underestimate the New Zealand report on
on the its trade agreement with China
underestimated not only by 500 percent
what they said is they knew Zenon would
reach a level of exports in 20 years
that they actually reached in 20 months
so economic analysis is frequently wrong
it's based on your fundamental
assumptions the problem is the
assumptions have been that we won't be
able to do any of the things suggested
in this paper in this plan and clearly
if we can't do any of the things suggest
in this plan then the numbers are going
to be very very different with respect
to the Irish Board of really quickly
we've proposed a lot of technical
solutions we've proposed moving people
to trust a trader we've proposed being
more exemptions for small businesses
we've proposed WTO waivers all kinds of
things frankly III could propose 500
things that could solve the the Irish
border it is not a technical problem it
is a diplomatic problem and one of the
things that we have suggested is what we
actually need to do is to have pragmatic
people on both sides of the border who
are willing to listen to technical
solutions and give them a fair hearing
and if that happened I think we could
solve this problem
much much more readily thank you keys
were and the politicians on the panel
the sort of question of how much
frictions too much friction um the key
challenge is to minimize friction
whether it's Dover or whether it's in
relation to our land board
and today's paper has you know clear
proposals for doing that and you have
you know it's not it's not just the IEA
Singh saying this you have both the head
of HMRC and the head of the revenue in
the Republic of Ireland saying they they
don't need physical infrastructure at
the border you see a trend throughout
the world to you know essentially adopt
a similar approach to customs
declaration as as companies already do
regularly with v80 returns there are all
sorts of ways in which with political
will we can ensure that our borders
function effectively just as well after
brexit as they do now and I think we
also need to remember that the European
you needs is subject to legal
obligations it undertakes as a member of
the World Trade Organization and those
include the lands groundbreaking customs
facilitation treaty agreed by the WTO
and endorsed by the European Union only
relatively recently and then there's
article 8 of the Lisbon Treaty which
obliges the European Union to maintain
cooperative relationships with its
neighbours and you know some of the
scare stories about year-ago slow at the
border and blockage in Cali they would
actually be unlawful in terms of the
European Union's obligations on the
international stage with political will
we can resolve these questions to keep
trade flowing between us in the European
Union it's in both sides of the
negotiation that we exercise that
political will and deliver a free trade
agreement between us Thank You Carlton
and from ITV News you may have some good
ideas here about hard to keep trade
flowing across the Irish border the
Prime Minister has ideas about that too
but the European Union until those ideas
can be shown to work still wants a
backstop in the withdrawal agreement in
case those ideas don't work how does any
of this get you over that difficulty
about the Irish backstop and if I may
one about
broader brexit policy for the
politicians on the panel it has been
suggested that the Home Secretary wants
to keep the door open to EU migrants for
two years after brexit I wonder what you
think about that doesn't make any
difference
Sankar perhaps you can take the back
stop question yeah well first of all
what I say about the back stop is it's
deliberate because one of the things
that we want to stress is that it's the
negotiating strategy has not worked here
and and and we're not going to try to
solve the issue of the moment with this
plan this is a comprehensive plan you
have to do all of it you can't take bits
and pieces of it so that's the first
thing I would say on the backstop we do
we do present proposals on what the
backstop should be but I was also point
out but we have moved from sufficient
progress being made on the Irish border
in order to get to a negotiation of the
future framework for the trade
relationship which is what it was
originally about to the need for a
comprehensive backstop to a backstop
that would not have a hard border at all
you know in the whole of the island of
Ireland as opposed to the language that
I think makes the most sense which is
not hardening the Irish border
consistent with the Good Friday
Agreement the peace process and the All
Ireland economy which is what I think we
know we should be aiming for that being
said I think the only backstop that
actually works and the one that we've
proposed here and people may disagree
with it is is is is you've got to have a
free trade agreement in goods you've got
to have zero tariffs in order for the
backstop to work that's got to be done
between the UK and the EU and the
advantage of this it finally takes back
the leverage on this issue and if it
even tusks they have all proposed a free
trade agreement with the UK so the
notion that the backstop would be an FTA
between the UK and EU basic FTA goods
tariffs going to zero and the
mitigations that we have suggested here
I think is an eminently sensible
backstop and we will commend it to both
the Irish the European Commission and
the UK government so if we have laid
that out here and I think it's again I
think it's a diplomatic issue but the
concern I have about the way the Irish
issue is played out is it's very very
dangerous
if there is in fact a technical and
diplomatic solution to this problem and
what the Irish government have done
particularly by hanging on to this
particular issue is you'll get if this
results in no free-trade agreement at
all between the UK and the EU then the
British government is going to be faced
with a choice they're going to be faced
with a choice which is either we're
going to have food price inflation
because we've got you know Tetra tariffs
on agricultural products all we're going
to have to lower unilaterally or
agri-food tariffs which is going to
cause mass and that would have to be on
an MFM basis and that would cause
massive damage to the Irish beef
industry so this is a very dangerous
situation I think there are pragmatic
and technical solutions to this I think
we should advance them before we have a
problem of our own making
can I go saucily the politician wanna
come in on the immigration question the
president thinking of the Home Secretary
I think the newspaper story about the
Home Secretary I'm not entirely sure to
what extent that's really news because
those kind of rights would have been
already entailed in the immigration in
the implementation period but can I just
say something much more significant
about this first of all this country now
needs to have a proper discussion of
what we think the purpose of our
immigration policies and from that it
will flow what it will be and we have
done the focus groups with change
Britain both with people who voted leave
and those who voted remain and it's
quite amazing how how short a period it
takes for both groups to say a
merit-based point system which is
actually equal treatment for everyone is
the best way forward and that the second
one is we should not underestimate any
significant achievement in the United
Kingdom in the wake of the referendum
all across Europe minor parties who
focus on immigration for all the wrong
reasons have attracted enormous support
from the voters in some countries
they're holding the government's to
ransom what we've achieved in the United
Kingdom is a debate on immigration will
be conducted by the two major parties
and
two major front benches in hope in a
rational and sensible way and that is
how it should be done Bianca thank you
Bianca noble o CN n could you elaborate
on what it is specifically in the Prime
Minister's white paper that would
prohibit independent free trade deals
with other countries and participating
in plurilateral partnerships from your
analysis and any discussions with
officials from other potential trading
partners cycle I think that's really one
for you you mentioned that you took off
the table but if any of our panel to
come in on that as well just catch my
eye yeah yeah essentially what what and
we have two written the paper that I'd
refer you to that sort of discusses this
in great detail the the issue is and
without going into a long speech about
it the harmonization to the EU rulebook
by treaty in goods and agri-food even
though it's for the trade ranges means
that you cannot negotiate on those
things with another party so if if you
want services concessions for example
from the US or from any other party and
you say to them that you can't you want
those things yourself but you can't give
them what they want on goods and
agriculture for example which we would
not be able to do you know they'll tell
you to go and pounce out I mean not that
one ago she ation won't go very far and
that is exactly what the US has done I
mean the interesting thing with the u.s.
is that the key things they want are in
goods and agriculture and yes they're
willing to have nice conversations with
us but unless we can do those things
there won't be any serious serious deal
and that's what they reinforced in my
trip over there last week in the report
we cite to three different to former
GAAP Council chairs and the former
deputy USTR from Australia New Zealand
and the u.s. who all said this takes
your independent trade policy off the
table it there's a confusion here I
think sometimes in what you can legally
do and what you can practically do you
may have the legal right to negotiate a
trade deal but if no one wants to
negotiate with you it's not a very
useful right so that's the the issue the
CP TPP has a
very specific set of regulatory measures
in its regulatory coherence chapter and
if you don't control your rulebook
they're not you're not going to be able
to negotiate with them and frankly every
country that we'd want to negotiate with
because of the nature of our of our
economy is going to want the same things
and they're all precluded by by checkers
now there is a way that I think you can
take some of the things as some of the
ideas in checkers the the ideas and
checkers on services on mutual
recognition of occupations these things
are reasonable things on which you can
build a construct and agreement but you
know the notion of a common rulebook if
it was genuinely a common rulebook
arrived at by both the UK and the EU in
the form of an advanced trade agreement
or free trade plus as David calls it
that's perfectly fine you know that
that's that that's not a problem the
problem is what is your scope of
authority to act and if you don't have
it which the checkers certainly doesn't
have it then then then you may as well
stay in the customs you'd in a single
market let me take another question I
will come to the panel again right at
the point you made earlier in fact you
just referred to about what the US is
saying about the prospect of a trade
deal under checkers
who exactly was it you were talking to
on the US side who said that the deal
was impossible yeah I'm not gonna reveal
names of USTR officials but what I will
refer you to is the very detailed
statement of the former US ambassador to
the WTO and former deputy USTR Peter
Algar who is very clear in his
assessment of of what checkers does for
your trade policy and I'd also refer you
to the statements of Alan Oxley who's
the former Australian ambassador to the
WTO former GATT council chairman and
founder of the cannes group and he's he
said some very specific things also
about why this takes your trade policy
off the table okay let me one final
question yes
we wait till the microphone gets to you
Matt day them from the Sun and to the
Tory politicians on the panel are you
going to set a deadline she doesn't what
will you do that dream of doing such
thing and Theresa okay we've got time
for one more so so succinct where are
politicians
let me take John mate at the front here
just wait to the microphone gets to you
John a politician and I'm not a
journalist I'm a businessman and I do
think it's absolutely essential that the
business view is heard in this debate I
campaigned on behalf of business Britain
in the East of England and I think this
plan represents a route map to the
brexit prize that you've referred to
because what business is crying out for
irrespective of what their view is on
the referendum is certainty and on the
topic of friction which seems to have
crept in as a euphemism all British
businesses deal with friction it's what
you do and they're very successful at
doing it it's one of the reasons why our
trade with the rest of the world is
increasing it's also one of the reasons
why our trade with Europe is declining
because the regulations that British
businesses have to go through are
holding them back my question is a very
simple one on timing and there's both
the trade policy and there's a political
question to it we're at the final stages
our brexit what is the time scale on
which it's possible to implement a trade
deal and how quickly would it take to
get the political will to do it thank
you thank you very much thank you let me
start with you and then go down the
panel with any other closing thoughts
that you Shankar all the rest of our
panelists wish to give particularly on
timetable and the voice of business John
was interesting I think on the voice of
business you know we've heard a lot from
managers of the UK EU supply chain and
managers of the EU UK supply chain will
always tell you that what they want is
no
I mean that's obviously what they're
going to tell you we think there are
other businesses though business is not
only those people it's also businesses
of the future it's entrepreneurs its
global businesses it's a whole range of
people who we don't tend to hear very
much from and I think the role of
business in this is to ask yourself what
do you want the world to look like you
know what kind of regulatory system
trading environment do you actually want
for the world and then to tell the
managers of the UK EU supply chain how
they use this big event which is the UK
adopting an independent trade and
regulatory policy for the first time how
do you use that to achieve your goals
so if you want you know better IP
protection if you want less anti
competitive regulation whatever it
happens to be how do you use that I
think the problem is that a lot of the
big global businesses now are basically
just asking their UK you supply chains
what do they want and obviously they're
getting the answer no change well that's
not good for shareholders that's not I
would argue that's not the chief
executive doing his job but but I think
there are all these huge potential gains
now on the timing question it's very
interesting this this question because
time is a dimension of a negotiation
which we have not used at all and which
the Europeans know how to use in only
one way which is to run the clock out so
your back is against the wall we have to
learn how to use time in the negotiation
it is amazing to me in any trade
negotiation or frankly any negotiation
how time expands the closer you get to
the deadline so much can be achieved in
the final you know 36 48 hours is
extraordinary how how much can actually
be achieved when people really have you
know their back against the wall the way
we use time to our advantage is by doing
the things that we can do that we have
control over unilaterally and also with
other trading partners who are
predisposed to war that all towards us
who have goodwill towards us do as much
of those things as you can so you're
setting up the chessboard and then
you'll find that the EU will have a very
different approach to your
proposals and your ideas I will defer to
domestic timings to the three people who
still have a vote on all this which I'm
afraid I no longer have and just add
that dimension from the European Union
side we are leaving and they the reason
why I think we need to start using time
because there are also up against time
is the European elections next year
you've got to remember that if you look
at the composition of national
governments across Europe that will be a
pretty you respect euro skeptic European
Parliament they're going to be faced
with I mean just what kind of a me piece
do you think Hungary Poland Sweden Italy
Austria is gonna return you also have
got a new Commission and I think it is
in a much in their interest to actually
do those deals whether that current set
of people within their current set of
the politics as it is in ours and I
think we need to use that tension just a
little bit more who spoke made a very
good point that the friction of
businesses faces not just at the border
it's all a regulatory friction that
exists in their marketplace and the
clumsy and often protectionist
regulation that the European Union
generates is an order of magnitude
greater than any friction and the border
could ever be and in the report is a
very good example talking about reached
and the various people's opinions of it
as a chemical regulation and I'll
reiterate Shanker's point that big
corporations primary interest is keeping
things as stable as possible over the
next few years they're not taking a very
long-term view on this and of course
nobody represents the companies that
don't exist yet the real threat of
checkers is to the new businesses the AI
businesses the genetics businesses the
other high-tech businesses where we're
going to be world leaders but we're not
even going to be deciders over our own
regulations that's going to be done by
the European Union normally against
their interests timing it's not just the
last 48 hours is sometimes the last 48
minutes or the last 48 seconds
in negotiation when the pressure really
comes to bear and this is the point it's
the interplay between time and pressure
and what's going to happen in the next
few months because really there's an
effective hard deadline before Christmas
sometimes just because they need to
ratify and they need to put in place
legislation the pressure on all sides
going to go up and people forget you
know if we end up with a tariff based
World Trade Organization outcome German
car sales in this country will drop by
probably a third I mean like that German
dairy sales this country dropped by 2/3
and you can do the same numbers for
Belgium the Netherlands Ireland you've
heard about French winemakers and so on
so the pressure will be on both sides so
the point under those circumstances the
tactical point of those homes is to have
your plans as well advanced and as
concrete as possible right down to the
legal text is very good that there's a
there's a draft example chapter at the
end of this book but the government as
well my last instruction virtually to my
department was draft the legal text for
the free trade plus arrangement so
you've got it to work from if you've got
that to work from the time spinning time
wasting activities the European
Commission which we see lots of in the
last two years fail in the face of the
need of the work of the 27 to have a
deal and to be able to recognize a deal
which is in their interest check that
it's Parkinson's law that work expands
to fill the time available but it also
shrinks to fill the time available and
they will suddenly discover as David's
been saying that they need to do things
quickly and they need to get a move on
and that's what the European Union does
just remember that the Greek bailout was
agreed every weekend regardless of all
the regulations that said it was
completely impossible they sorted out
the legal niceties and the cost to the
German taxpayer somewhat later and I'd
also refer you to on the regulatory bit
pages 25 to 29 of the report against
there a number of regulations reach
method solvency - and the key to
remember about all those regulations is
that they help encumber
and they make it difficult for
competitors now I would like them
because I'm still the chairman of
Somerset Capital Management and as an
established company method two is
fantastic because we can afford to take
on a new compliance officer and deal
with all this when I set up my business
in 2007 if all these regulations had
then been in place which had no
protection to customers of any kind
whatsoever it would simply have made it
harder to do if not impossible so as a
fat incumbent I'm quite happy but if I
were a thin and hungry entrepreneur I'd
be very dissatisfied and I think we
should support the thin and hungry
entrepreneurs
I agree that a key part of the brexit
fries is taking back control of the way
we regulate our economy we will all this
cross-party consensus and we will want
to maintain our high standards in
relation to employment protection the
environment you know consumer protection
the key gain is to be able to decide how
we deliver those outcomes as someone who
spent six years in the European
Parliament I can attest personally that
the regulation making in Europe is
distinctly suboptimal and it's there's a
huge potential for growth and prosperity
if we regain control of how to ensure
that we continue to deliver those those
vital outcomes but we do it in a way
which is better suited to our own
domestic circumstances which is more
efficient which is less costly and which
promotes rather than inhibits
competition and I just like to close by
saying countries around the world do
their trading arrangements on the basis
of free trade agreements of the sort
that are advocated by the IEA document
today we're not asking for the world
we're not asking for anything abnormal
we are asking the European Union to
treat us in a broadly similar way they
do many other of their trading partners
you know this document demonstrates it's
a further illustration that we can make
a freight free trade agreement work
including in relation to the border on
the island and Ireland and now it's time
to table attacks put it on the table and
to work thank you before I get hard copy
this document I know they're on a huge
number of copies here it is free to
download on the iOS web site I owe you K
for those of you who know me well will
know why I want to give particular
thanks to Jacob and Chris from the BBC
as a devout Saints fan I have a running
joke that I always have to mention
Southampton in any public appearance but
by mentioning mentioning Southampton
docks Jacob and Chris got me off the
hook so thank you very much indeed
to them and to underscore our non
political status I understand that John
McDonnell is just taking to his feet and
I'm sure like me you will not want to
miss a single word of the shadow
Chancellor's speech thank you very much
joining some please join me in thanking
our super panel thank you very much